what would you like to hear a rap about
two at the same time you said Benedict
Arnold who is Benedict Arnold did you
say it you say a foreigner Wow how
offensive yeah we don't like him who is
Benedict Arnold a guy from American
history so what you did there was you
said a name and hoped no one would
really dig any deeper a guy someone who
knows American history who is Benedict
Arnold he's a traitor well how long ago
and you still upset about it let go guys
Benedict Arnold a traitor in the
Revolutionary War so then that was the
rebel war was the war of independence
that was when my people lost to your
people yes we don't actually learn about
it in our schools obviously there was a
minor disagreement and we withdrew
peacefully there's nothing here for us
nothing here that we wanted what
happened they got angry and threw tea in
the sea that's what we learn about it
you threw a hissy fit and we're like no
Benedict Arnold a traitor during the
Revolutionary War that's a great
suggestion thank you and someone over
there you said something to do with
North Dakota what was the full
suggestion Fargo North Dakota
oh cool Fargo North Dakota I know that
is Fargo North Dakota
Benedict Arnold the traitor for the
Revolutionary War we'll come to the
middle you guys seem so well-informed
about the traitor II and treacherous
Ness what what what was the first bit
mud wrestling amazing mud wrestling I
like it mud wrestling Fargo North Dakota
no my mother my mother would not approve
so that makes it sound weird no okay so
mud wrestling Benedict Arnold Fargo
North Dakota this wedge over here what's
it gonna be bad teeth all right mate all
right yeah bad teeth that's specifically
a gibe named at the English isn't it
yeah yeah yeah bad teeth okay and that
didn't really come from this wedge did
it so so they took that we'll still take
it we'll get one final one let's make it
a quintet what's it gonna be shush
stop being so you just like losing a war
yeah whatever you you said Game of
Thrones I feel I don't want to spoil
anything for anyone so I won't take that
what did someone say Charlie of Scotland
bonny bonny Prince Charlie amazing
that's some nice British history that no
one here is going to know anything about
Bonnie Prince Charlie of Scotland bad
teeth
Benedict Arnold mud-wrestling and Fargo
North Dakota
I like those suggestions thank you for
them this then to close out the night
there's a little thing called a
freestyle made up on the spot placed in
Italian those suggestions none of its
prepared none of its rehearsed it's
gonna be pretty cool should we roll that
tape good sir let's see how we do you
all seem very confused as to what's
happening
if a Spring Break I know I wanna go off
to North Dakota take a cold breaking
Fargo it's the movie by the Coen
brothers but I got the knowledge me they
filmed in nine Fargo an apology to break
the illusion yes the solution they moved
in a couple CES over for the film in
funny cheaper rates that's the fact that
you know if you frequently go to a Coen
Brothers show they do queuing is the
Fargo yeah I can see they had the guy
who cuts down that tree the statue he
cries on like an onion man with an axe
and his name Paul Bunyan a know very
little about him mysterious American
history yeah they never teaching us
about the things that happen don't we
still so saw a broken up about losing
that war revolutionaries the solution to
II who was to take her money and drop it
in the scene you were like we would
rather kick up purple lava and drop nice
tea leaves right in the harbor that's
okay I'm so sad burn it happened I know
one guy was involved in his name Sam
Adams he's a Boston Patriot yeah hardly
learn about the others but a great tea
party but Benedict Arnold he offended
you hated you ever he was a friend to
the blue eye and read of the Union Jack
he was a traitor what he knew stab you
in the back then probably run away you
wanna regress into the past mud
wrestling when I'm getting on the grass
with my friends I like to make it nice
and slimy I make a big mud pool
circumference not tiny I'm like take
your bikinis on and get in here a very
large pool got a big diameter it's got
the mud wall two walls I see the ha
sweaty action with the girl one girl on
like yeah
get her in a choke hold a suplex you're
going down like you do it all role sex
no I said we reject that phrase but
wrestling was such a mad craze I wanna
get down underneath the mess that stuff
of white English teens we haven't got
great dentistry in my country but that's
okay I think we'll all agree you get
implants they straighten them out and in
LA when you show in your mat they need
to be straight and white like myself but
that is okay bad is not good for your
health you pick a new set of retainers
of the shelf
your paper route with money and you need
that wealth then if your smile is so
bright as to disarm Lee I'm just
happening like Bonnie Prince Charlie
Bonnie means happy means filled with
glee that's another TV show you should
all see clean not Game of Thrones
it's far too bloody I'm not Scottish but
Charlie was my buddy so I'll continue
the rap in the accent to the throne of
England wanted to ascend it didn't
happen though losing with the army you
don't know the history neither do i
Charlie not Dean Charles like the prints
that we go he likes her where to kill he
would expose his ball all the sky army
yeah they would follow it wasn't quite
as good as fine as William Wallace thank
you very much
please watch more playlists and
subscribe there's light coming all those
things shouting five